when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to
fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
thank you
see that's not so scary is it
just you your sister and me
you're doing okay sorry
[Music]
it's okay
so it's just in your head
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these manifestations
[Music]
supposed to be
[Applause]
dad you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
[Music]